good morning uh so we're going to kick
off a little causal inference theme for
the next two talks so uh we have uh a
data scientist from conco um based in
Zurich uh so uh we we're going to talk
about causal inference libraries and
without further Ado please welcome Kevin
Klein thank you very
much um hello everybody as was just said
my name is Kevin I work at quano as a
data scientist learn engineer and today
I would like to talk about causal
influence libraries what they already do
and what I would like them to do uh we
will talk we will sort of nourish that
discussion with the following agenda
first I will try to motivate why one
would use Concepts and tooling from
causal inference in the first place then
I'll try to motivate why one wants
heterogenity when using these uh these
these these tools from causal inference
I will then try to give you an idea on a
high level as to how can one can
actually estimate such heterogeneous
treatment effects this notion from
causal inference I'll then try to give
some code examples of how this can be
done with uh with set libraries and and
lastly I will talk about a couple of
things that I personally am missing from
Eon ML and Cal ml uh this discussion uh
walking through these topics will be uh
will be followed by a data set that
revolves around roro consumptions and as
you may or may not know Roto can be
prepared in in two major ways either by
stirring it a lot over a long dur of
time uh which which takes a lot of
effort it's very time consuming or it
can be prepared in a very Cutthroat
fashion basically just pouring together
the stock and the rice and just waiting
for it to be done and in our data set in
our scenario we don't only cook the Roto
but Roto is also consumed by consumers
and what's now special is that they can
pay as much as they desire for the
consumption of the rotto so they
determine the outcome and now naturally
given these two options of preparing
rotto we wonder should we be stirring
does it pay off uh to stir in terms of
the payment we receive from the
consumers and this is the kind of
question we want to answer with these
causal influence libraries how can we
make a policy it's about decision making
about intervening into the real world um
and and that's really the Gateway into
causal inference um and in order to
motivate that I have a violent plot here
on the right hand side of resort
consumptions that we did observe and in
particular it is petitioned into two on
the left left hand side the reso
consumptions that were not stirred and
on the right hand side the reso
consumptions that were indeed stirred
and what we observe right away is that
on average the stirred resi led to a
higher payment that we see on the y-
axis that's an observation that's all
fine and well but now our question is
what happens if we intervene if we take
this Orange Point from the left hand
side that was in the observe data not
stirred what would happen to it if we
kept everything the same the consumer's
property remain the same the date of the
consumption Remains the Same the chef's
property remain the same but now the
rotto is stirred what happens and I can
think of two scenarios that happen on
the left hand side we see positive
treatment effect so basically the fact
that we now stir increases the access
payment we receive by the consumer or
the scenario on the right hand side
where as I said we change nothing else
other than the stirring so the payment
doesn't change I can think of these two
scenarios who here thinks that the the
left scenario is what will actually
happen if we do
intervene okay some some few who thinks
the right hand side will take
place who thinks that whenever a speaker
asks aob then probably NE a no B is
correct you smart uh because we can't
tell it depends uh we don't know what's
going to happen if we intervene a
priority in order to have a sense of
what's going to happen we need to have
an understanding of the causal mechanism
that is behind the data generating
process and here I have two explanations
one on the left hand side one on the
right hand side for this correlation
between stirring and higher payments on
the left hand side we see a direct
causal impact from stirring onto the
payment which means that if we stir the
payment will directly increase and
that's why we saw this correlation in
The observed data set on the right hand
side we do not have a direct causal link
from stirring to payment but we have
What's called the common confounder
which in this case is the chef's rating
being a proxy for the chef's skill set
and so the the correlation we observed
was mainly due to the fact that chefs
who are great at cooking happen to stir
even though the stirring doesn't have
any effect on the on the payment of the
res itself and this kind of Distinction
of the Shelf machine learning models are
not well equipped to to make they're
just not well at capturing these these
distinctions these subtleties and that's
why we used uh tools from causal
inference to really capture the causal
effects that are behind
data um so now I've tried to motivate
causal inference but now what about
heterogenity uh why do we why do we care
about heterogenity which I alluded to in
the beginning and I think there that's a
bit of a rhetorical question because I
would say the world is heterogenous and
so here we see a histogram of rotto
consumption so every point was one
consumption of Roto say an8 Chef Johns
was AO at 2:40 p.m. and on the x-axis we
see the treatment effects so the extra
payment we received thanks to the resort
being stirred so again keeping
everything else the same how much is the
access we get by stirring in payment and
here we see that we have a
non-negligible cluster at around zero so
we receive receive basically the same
amount whether we stir or not in US
dollars but we also have a cluster
around too so there are some
consumptions depending on the properties
of the consumer and or the chef uh in
which the stirring actually increases
the payment receives non- negligibly by
$2
others uh and if we were in a
homogeneous world then we would
basically just see a d Delta function
just one bar at say 1.8 where everybody
pays more and I think this is very
intuitive if you think of say medication
I think it's it everybody can easily
understand that uh a medication given to
a 25-year-old pregnant woman will have a
different treatment effect than giving
to a three-year-old toddler and that's
my point here that the real world is
heterogeneous and therefore we want to
capture that heterogenity and we want to
capture it for a decision making for
defining a policy and so here in this
histogram it's the same histogram than
before I just added this orange vertical
bar which is the assumed cost of
stirring a resoto so here we now say
okay we know um our bookkeepers told us
it costs one US dollar to to stir one
rotto uh basically and and once we have
that information and we also have the
treatment effects uh displayed on the
x-axis we can just compare both values
because the treatment effect tells us
how much do we get extra by stirring and
if we can then compare that to the cost
we can simply split up the consumptions
into profitable and loss making in terms
of stiring that's a very naive and
straightforward policy that we can then
Define if we have access to these
heterogeneous treatment effects we
usually don't what we can do or can hope
to do is to estimate those and that's
why in the policy definition we see a
toall hat and not the tow that we see on
the xaxis of the histogram because we
usually don't have this information but
we try to estimate it and then derrive
uh a straightforward policy off of
it so I I just motivated that if we have
this to hat a policy is straightforward
which is compare the treatment effect to
the cost how do we get that um and uh I
think it would be all well and nice if
our data looked like this where we
basically have a table where every row
is a consumption of Roto we have the
covariates say the age of the consumer
the chef's rating and then we have the
outcomes for both situations
so we have an outcome for the non-red
resoto as well as an outcome for the
stirred resoto if we have this kind of
information we can basically just
subtract one from each other and we know
what the individual treatment effect is
right so we have this this causal
information of the treatment effect
right away and we could just use an
off-the-shelf uh machine learning
approach and use this treatment effect
as a label and the Machine learning
approach would spit out a quanti a
causal quantity that would be great but
as the title of the slide suggests that
is only a desire uh in reality
we Face the so-called fundamental
problem of causal inference which means
that we only ever observe the outcome
under one treatment variant we can never
observe more than one simultaneously
unless you assume kind of parallel
universes because surely you can you can
prepare two rortos for an maybe even
twice prepared by Chef John but the the
the overall circumstances will never be
identical there's only one uh reality
that we observe and therefore
unfortunately we can't know the
individual treatment effect we we can't
know it so we can't just train on that
and and and hope to just predict that
this we can't do what we can however do
is uh to resort to this uh notion of the
conditional average treatment effect
which is subtly different from the
individual treatment effect which is an
expected value of this difference so we
can't compute the difference but we can
hope to estimate the expected value of
this difference conditioning on these
coari and this conditioning here is
really important because that's our
heterogenity right this this a are the
Co variates which express say the
consumer's age and the chef's rating
which allows for the heterogenity in a
policy um and please please be be aware
if I now say cage or conditional average
treatment effect or heterogeneous
treatment effect these are all the same
thing in the literature they use as as
synonyms and and now we would now like
to estimate this expected value and
there's very sophisticated tooling uh uh
in in causal influ to do so and as far
as I can tell all of this tooling iies
on three very technical uh assumptions
which I don't have the the time to uh go
into right now but just one thing that I
would like to tell you is that if your
data that you're using um stems from
randomized control trial so where you
basically flip a coin every time to
decide whether you stir or not there's
nothing else that determines whether you
stir or not only the flipping coin then
you already get two of these three
assumptions for free if you're using
observational data that does not stem
from a proper randomized control trial
then you actually need to put in the
work and validate these assumptions in
order to estimate these Kates these
conditional average treatment effects
once you have indeed validated these
assumptions you can uh use a shiny fancy
new tool from causal inflence that's
called meta Learners they sit at the
intersection of econometrics uh
statistics and machine learning and uh
they are basically Kate models so they
are models estimators that estimate this
causal quantity and importantly they
rely on arbitrary machine learning
estimators inside of them so these
little triangles could be anything you
want they could be a multi-layer
perceptron a booster tree a random
Forest a linear logistic regression that
doesn't impact sort of the definition of
the metal learner it is more General
than that and uh some of the examples
for such metal Learners they all start
with one or two letters for some reason
or the S learner the T learner the all
learner and whatnot and uh similarly but
slightly differently from a regular uh
machine learning uh scenario we don't
only have two inputs but we have three
inputs we have the treatment assignments
so basically did someone get a St reso
or a non- St resoto we have the
covariates X which you could also think
of as features in a regular machine
learning context and The observed
outcomes y we don't have these two
outcomes non St and stirred because that
that's only that's not reality we only
see one observed outcome that is a
function of the coari and of the
treatment assignment what we get out is
this tow hat and this tow hat is a
function of x because it is a
heterogeneous treatment effect so for
every observation in the data set we get
an estimate for how much uh the extra
stirring brings in payment so to
say and the T learner is one example of
such meta Learners and uh here we see a
depiction of what happens at training
time so again we see these three inputs
the treatment assignments the covariates
and the outcomes and what the t-not
learner now does is it partitions this
data set into two on the one hand the co
and their outcomes for the non-red
consumptions and the covariates and the
treatments for the stirred consumptions
at the bottom what it then does is to
feed these two partitions into regular
machine learning regressors so the these
regressors these triangles are just
trying to predict why based on a just
off the-shelf stuff and and and by doing
that the T learner then has one model
that is trained to St Resort and one
model that's trained to non-st resi at
prediction time we then receive our coar
so we just see a new consumer arriving
we know a new Chef could cook to Roso
and we haven't observed any uh treatment
assignments we haven't decided yet
whether we want to St or not now we want
the tner to tell us whether we want to
St or not and at prediction time the T
learner then feeds these covariates
through both just learned models gives
us an estimate for the payment uh in the
context of St resi gives us an estimate
for the payment in the context of non-st
resi and then just basically computes uh
the difference of both and that then
magically gives us a consistent estimate
for this conditional average treatment
effect well just relying on machine
learning models inside but then getting
it to a causal estimate and um
importantly the t- learner is really
this whole thing the plumbing and wiring
and and shuffling data around this logic
that's the metal learner it's not just
regressing a y based on
X um as you can tell the tner is very
simple and intuitive which is great for
getting used to metal learners but but
uh most metal Learners uh are more
sophisticated have more uh greater
theoretical properties and also perform
better in practice but they're just a
bit harder to understand what's going on
um uh yes so now I've tried to give you
an idea of how we can uh conceptually or
on paper estimate these conditional
average treatment effects that we can
then directly use in our policy so how
does this look like in code and there's
two um two python open source libraries
that allow you to to train these meta
Learners one's called econ ml developed
primarily by Microsoft research and the
other is called cosl developed by Uber
and importantly both Implement a lot of
these meta Learners so not only say the
T learner but a whole family of them and
all of these meta Learners have an
sklearn estimator uh protocol so they
have the the regular fit predict fit
predict um uh method that you used to in
machine learning and uh this is then
again our data set that we now want to
use uh these libraries on we have some
covariates the age the nationality the
chef's rating and whether the chef uses
a gas Stu or not and then since this is
simulated data and only because it's a
simulated data we have access to this m
x which is basically the base outcome so
that's uh the the outcome that is
captured by all of the covariates and
has nothing to do with the treatment
assignment so so to say the the the
outcome under no stirring and Tower VX
which is the true treatment effect which
we never have in reality which we only
have because this is a simulation um so
we have access to this so that we can
evaluate our approach just as a toy
example what we would always observe in
reality are the t's and the Y's the
actual treatment assignments whether we
stirred or not and the Y's which are
just observe payments and these
quantities are then added together uh we
can now throw this data which is thought
as a pan data frame quite simply um uh
and and uh yeah into into a c model in
the first blog we basically just one hot
en code of Soul C categorical variable
in the second block we then Define our
meta learner and here we use a so-called
R learner that is here implemented by C
LEL uh it goes by the name of Base AR
regressor the class and we can see right
away that it does have these three
components I said these metal Learners
always have several components inside
that are arbitrary machine learning
models and here we can see that one's
called the outcome learner one's called
the effect learner and one's called the
propensity learner and we instantiate
them all with arbitrarily chosen L GBM
booster trees either regressing or
classifying in the last line we see what
I said on the previous slide that we
have this regular SK learn API so we
just have a fit call that now instead of
just the X and Y also takes treatment
vector and and uh a predict call that
gives us the estimates of the
conditional average treatment effects
that we can then directly use to define
a policy we can just see is the estimate
greater than $1 yes then please stir and
if it's smaller than $1 don't stir
fairly fairly straightforward
um since this a simulation we have
access to the ground truth data on the
y-axis so the actual treatment effect
and on the x-axis we see what the the
code from the previous slide spits out
and what we see is that without doing
any architecture search or without doing
any hyper paramet optimization just with
default parameters we pick up some
signal we certainly don't uh estimate
the treatment effects perfectly but we
but we certainly pick up some signal
that's all great and uh I think Co andal
you should totally check them out
they're they're great libraries um and
I'm really thankful for them being open
source and for being able to use them
but as is always the case there are some
things that are not perfect for everyone
and I personally have some pains and
problems with both that sometimes make
me look like that sad
programmer um and one of these pains
that I sometimes have is the dealing
with categorical features and uh I just
refer to lbm which is a very popular
choice for all prediction problems on
tabular data sets and one of its great
features is that it allows you you to do
categorical features natively so you do
not have to one hot and Cote them and on
the one hand that's nice because you
don't have to take care of just creating
all these Comm comms but on the other
hand it also is advantageous for your
learning algorithm because now instead
of saying is Iraqi is Irani Israeli you
can just say nationality and the model
has the signal the the the the
information that these values are
mutually exclusive because if you just
split them up into into binary columns
then thisinformation is lost and
uh you might know a decision tree from
on the left hand side where the inner
node split on numerical value values
with a greater or equal relationship and
if you then use this feature by lbm lbm
actually learns the subsets of values to
group together and that's really
powerful um there's like nice theory
that explains to you why this can be uh
why this can help your learning
algorithm a lot but there also the
practice and so here I ran this with our
resulted data set and on the y- axis see
the root means squ error of the
conditional average treatment effects
and we see that for small sample sizes
the the darker blue so the categorical
feature from nbm leads to a way better
result than using one hot
encoding um with a fair amount of
repetitions and so that's all really
cool that lbm has this and it's also
really cool that meta Learners are in
principle agnostic of any machine
learning model you use internally as
these components you can use lbm for for
cosl and eonl but unfortunately um cosl
and
eonl prevent you from using this
categorical feature uh and can lead to
silent failures actually they don't tell
you that it doesn't work um another pain
and problem I have in practice uh is
using already trained components so as
we now said several times these meta
Learners rely on several components
inside of them and you can always fit
the entire thing together by just
calling the dot fit of the meta learner
but sometimes you might want want to use
already trained components say for
instance if you're doing hyperparameter
optimization of the overall thing but
also of the components you don't always
want to retrain everything right because
that just leads to a massive increase in
runtime due to the combinatorics uh and
so I would really be excited if I could
um sort of train one component really
well maybe hyper param to optimize it
and then reuse it for everything that
happens with the metal that's to my the
best of my knowledge not really possible
with eonl and and Co
a third paino is predicting with um
components and so uh similarly to the
previous paino I would like to evaluate
individual components every now and then
I would like to uh get predictions of
what they actually do if I feed new data
to them so that I can also evaluate them
so that I don't only know what is the
overall metal learner doing but what are
also the individual components doing uh
to have a final granularity of improving
my my model basically that's also to my
knowledge not possible possible and my
last uh uh pain point is using distinct
covariant sets so usually we have this
one X that we use for everything but in
some cases you might have a strong
domain knowledge on how these individual
components work what kind of features
the the real data generating process
relies on and in that case you want to
restrict features that don't have
anything to do with the component such
that your model doesn't unnecessarily
overfit on it as you want to remove the
noise basically and and this is to my
knowledge also not possible with Eon and
coal um um I'm I'm running out of time
so I'll skip those what I would like to
tell you is that if you kind of like
caal inference if you find it cool and
if you find it cooler than aligning
elements on slides just just uh as I do
join us uh we we are always looking for
great people we're always hiring we are
also proud contributors to um to open
source uh come talk to me if you want to
know more or shoot us an email uh this
is a snapshot of some of the rools uh we
have open we're very flexible in terms
of rols in terms of locations um reach
out to to us and just lastly very
briefly thank you all for listening and
your patience special thanks to Dan e
Julie Matias and Nobert for their help
with this talk and shout out to M faku
for his amazing blog causal inflence for
the Brave and true and you can find the
slides on my GitHub thank you very
[Music]
much